the democrats prepare for their first
official debate democrats in the media
discover there's an actual crisis
at the border and google doesn't know
what nazis are i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
well a lot going on in the news and we
will get to all of those things
immediately so let us jump in we begin
with the democratic debate the
democratic debate is tonight the first
democratic debate are you excited i'm
does it feel like we've already had like
three of these and these will be endless
these democratic debates there are 25
democratic candidates
virtually everyone who's a registered
democrat in the united states
will be part of this debate well the
first debate
will feature some real big names my big
names i mean
nobodies the only big name in this
debate is elizabeth warren so she's got
the night all to herself
we'll see how many people actually tune
in just to watch elizabeth warren and
her magical plans
she has plans is what we keep hearing
from the media now they never actually
evaluate whether the plans are feasible
or workable
they never even assess whether her
proposed wealth tax which would
take a percentage of wealth from people
who have already paid taxes on their
income
whether that proposed wealth is even
constitutional they haven't assessed
whether any of those plans
would work financially whether they work
in terms of the
budget of the united states short answer
no they don't the fact is that the vast
growth in the united states budget is
driven
by out-of-control spending and that
out-of-control spending is driven by
entitlement programs
many of which she wants to add to
including medicare for all
if you took out medicare and social
security from the united states budget
the united states budget would be in
surplus it is social security and
medicare that have bankrupted the
country
to the point where 30 years from now 144
of our gdp will be spent on the national
debt
so that's going to be very very exciting
well anyway elizabeth warren
is leading the pack and we're going to
go through these candidates so that you
know
who exactly is going to be on stage in
this most important of debates
so you've got elizabeth warren fake
native american and
faux moderate who once upon a time was
in favor of things like school vouchers
and wrote books like the two income trap
in which she discussed the problem with
having two parents outside the household
working and now is such a progressive
leftist that she is threatening
bernie sanders flank and bernie sanders
is running a little bit scared from
elizabeth warren and that is largely
because
the the progressives in the media have
decided that elizabeth warren
is the hot new thing so she's going to
be on the stage
the other big name on the stage if you
can call him that is corey mcbooker so
cory booker the senator from new jersey
who's been desperate for attention
a man so manipulative that you can
actually see the gears moving behind his
eyes when he speaks
you can actually see him flipping the
anger switch up when it's time to be
angry
a man who is basically the mr potato
head of politics
he walks around and at a certain point
he decides that it's time for
the angry eyes and he reaches into his
back and pulls out the anger as he puts
them on then suddenly he's very sincere
cory booker so cory booker
will be on stage fresh off having shot
himself directly in the foot
by attacking joe biden and it back and
basically backfiring on him you've also
got bill de blasio a very large
groundhog killer
a crappy mayor of new york that nobody
likes and nobody understands why he's
even running
julian castro who is hanging around
basically in the hopes that somebody
will give him a cabinet slot
john delaney who if you're asking who
john delaney is
i join you in this query no one knows
who john delaney is
or why he's there he's basically just a
guy who walked in off the street and
they're like would you like to be in a
debate and he's like yeah
sounds good tulsi gabbard who is bashar
assad's favorite congressperson
jay inslee of washington state a
governor who has focused
so much on climate change that he's done
nothing about climate change in his
actual state emissions are not actually
down in the state of washington
amy klobuchar who's expected to be sort
of a moderate candidate
in this race is somebody who is going to
draw the middle in
and it turns out yeah not so much you
can't draw flies and then you've got
beto
beta o'rourke who has flamed out worse
than any candidate in recent memory
a man who started off with a money bomb
and then proceeded to
basically melt into shards
he's i've never seen a candidate melt
down quite as completely as beta
o'rourke it's pretty insane
from a launch on the cover of vanity
fair in the one shirt that he apparently
owns
to weirdo who eats dirt and was a furry
that transition's been rather rough for
beto have you ever seen such a fall from
grace i mean it's like a grace kelly
esque fall from
well that's actually a different kind of
fall and then you have tim ryan again
a congress person from ohio who is
supposed to be a moderate but has failed
to break out from the pack so
it will be a a cornucopia of boredom and
stupidity tonight
i hope that you're looking forward to it
the same way that i am we'll talk about
what's going to happen in that debate
in just one second first a rise in
geopolitical tensions have led to a
five-year high in gold prices
iran has announced it will break the
uranium stockpile limit they agree to
under the iran
nuclear deal is it a coincidence that
gold prices have been steadily rising
since the tanker bombings no
it is not it is not because number one
chaos breeds uncertainty and uncertainty
means people look for a safe haven as
i've been telling you for the past four
years gold is a safe haven against
uncertainty
is it part of your plan it should be
it's part of my plan hedge against
inflation hedge against uncertainty and
instability with precious metals my
savings plan is diversified yours should
be too
the company i trust with precious metal
purchases birch gold group
that's because i know them i've talked
with them and you can too you look back
historically and when the bottom falls
out of everything else
gold does tend to safeguard savings
birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers they've got
countless five-star reviews
a plus rating with the better business
bureau so go contact birch gold group
right now
get a free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
precious metals makes sense for you
they got that comprehensive 16-page kit
and it'll show you how gold and silver
can protect your savings
i can legally move that ira or 401k out
of stocks and bonds into a precious
metals ira if that's something you're
into
to get that no cost no obligation kit
all you have to do is text my name ben
to 47 47 47 again
text ben my name 247 4747 ben 247
47 47 okay so the democrats are worried
about
a clown car on stage and basically and
that's pretty much i think how they
should open the debate i think an actual
clown car
should drive up on stage the door should
open and
20 candidates should all climb over each
other to get out
like a scene from dumbo we found really
fantastic
okay so politico reports this week's
debates will be the first time millions
of americans meet the cast of democrats
trying to take out president donald
trump that's precisely what has the
party brass terrified yes i would be
terrified too
if you're leading candidates or an
octogenarian socialist who was so lazy
who was kicked out of a commune in the
1970s a fake native american
who has spent her career basically
lecturing people while picking up a half
million dollar salary from harvard law
school and then
proclaiming that she is some sort of
leader of the people
joe biden a gaff machine who has failed
in every presidential run he has ever
tried and whose only fame and notoriety
is due to the fact
that he lucked out by having barack
obama select him as his vice president
and kamala harris who is an ark right
those are those are your leading
candidates democrats congratulations
and they'll all be on stage trying to
outdo each other this is a big problem
because no one wants to be outflanked if
you're out flanked on that stage you got
a problem on your hands so instead what
you're going to get is
elizabeth warren saying things like i
want to relieve student debt for future
generations and bernie sanders saying
what about past generations
why cannot we relieve student debt for
abraham lincoln who only had two years
of schooling after all
and then you'll have joe biden sitting
off to the side going i remember once
when it'll be great
great entertainment so the democratic
party is a little bit worried about this
interviews with nearly 20 democratic
elected officials party chiefs
labor leaders and operatives the past
week revealed an error of foreboding
verging on alarm
that the debates will degenerate into a
two-night bare-knuckle brawl which
honestly that's why republicans should
watch this thing because you never know
what's going to happen guys i mean if
this turns mma
if this turns ground in pound it's going
to be good solid stuff
with the divisive 2016 democratic
primary fresh in their minds and the
current presidential candidates starting
to
take swipes at one another the fear is
that voters will be left with the
impression of a bickering
small-minded opposition party well maybe
that's because they will be left with
the proper impression because it is a
bickering small-minded opposition party
so
that's accurate randy weingarten who's
president of the american federation of
teachers and a member of the dnc
and this should just remind you folks
that the teachers unions are not friends
to your children they are friends to the
democratic party who promise them
in insane amounts of treasure and loot
randy weingarten says it's going to be a
scrum
a lot of people trying to score points
on each other and looking like scoring
points was more important than
communicating with the american people
that circular firing squad is not going
to help save our democracy or help
working families there are a few reasons
democrats think their presidential
hopefuls might escalate their attacks on
wednesday and thursday
well number one somebody has to break
out of the pack and this would be the
time to do it
cory booker has been attacking joe biden
kamala harris has been attacking
joe biden booker's not in the biden
debate kamala harris is it would not be
a surprise to see harris go after
joe biden bernie sanders meanwhile has
criticized biden for voting for the iraq
war and free trade deals
moderate candidates meanwhile have been
unloading on progressive opponents
governor john hickenlooper who is
not a relevant human being but is in the
bernie sanders debate has gone after
bernie sanders the big question tonight
is going to be whether anybody attacks
elizabeth warren
does anybody have the stones to go after
elizabeth warren are they all just going
to pretend that elizabeth warren isn't
the true threat lurking inside the party
it will be fascinating to see if amy
klobuchar for example goes after the
foolishness
of elizabeth warren's actual plans
that'll be kind of
fascinating it turns out that joe
biden's lead by the way
is starting to deteriorate in some of
the major states according to a new
poll from crooked media and change
research crooked media of course the far
left group that brings you pod save
america
they've put together a poll their poll
shows biden leading in iowa and south
carolina and bernie sanders
leading in new hampshire which is kind
of fascinating according to their
polling
joe biden is only up on the rest of the
field by nine points
so these polls are all over the place at
this point you've got the morning
console poll that has bernie sanders
that has joe biden all the way up at 38
and then you got this crooked media poll
that has joe biden all the way down
at 29 that's a 10 point gap
pretty astonishing okay and then bernie
sanders following at twenty percent
elizabeth warren at 19 percent
pete buda judge at 14 and then very sad
sad kamala harris all the way down at
five percent
cory booker at three and beto trailing
at three
according to that new poll joe biden
leads the democratic primary horse race
but
in the various states it's pretty close
in iowa biden is only up 27-20
over elizabeth warren they've got
sanders at 18 and buda judge at 17. so
that's a crowd right there
in south carolina that is the only place
where biden has a serious lead
according to the crooked media polling
group they say that he is up at 39
presumably because there are a lot of
black voters in the south carolina
democratic primary and that is where
biden's base of support is
followed by warren at 15 sanders at 13
and buda judge at 11.
one of the other things this poll is
showing is how closely grouped warren
sanders and buda judge are
in new hampshire sanders is actually
ahead at 28
biden is at 24 warren is at 21
it'd be fascinating to see sort of what
the breakdown here
is in terms of the voting population are
they oversampling young white people
because that would be
sampling the pod save america audience
presumably
but joe biden is the real question is is
not going to be for tonight the real
question is going to be
for tomorrow night the real question is
going to be what happens when joe biden
is on the stage
and all the guns train on joe biden well
one tactic is being made clear by the
new york times today i'll get to that in
just
one second first let's talk about
something we can all agree
is awesome saving money like your money
we may not all agree that saving
government money is awesome but saving
your money is really great the reality
is
if you're not shopping around you're
probably not saving money honey
is the way to do this it's a free tool
that you download to your computer's
browser while you shop online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts and then it
automatically applies the coupon with
the biggest savings to your cart at
checkout it is indeed like magic so i
use honey it's awesome just runs in the
background my computer doesn't bother me
until it's time for me to buy something
and it works at all the big websites i
mean you go to amazon
and you're going to save on the products
even the products at amazon
and i shop at amazon all the time i do
most of my shopping online that means
that honey has probably saved me at this
point hundreds of dollars and it can
save you lots of money
as well there's really no reason not to
use honey it's free to use it's easy to
install on your computer in just two
clicks
don't take it from me take it from our
listeners get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
ben that is joinhoney.com a lot of our
listeners have been using it and telling
us just how great it is you can be one
of them
joinhoney.com ben honey the smart
shopping assistant that will save you
time
as well as money go go check them out at
joinhoney.com
okay so as i say tonight it will be
interesting to see if anybody opens up
on elizabeth warren
tomorrow night joe biden's on stage and
that's going to be joe biden thrown in
with a pack of alligators
and you can see the new york times
setting up the groundwork for some of
these attacks
there's an article in the new york times
today called lock the sobs up
joe biden and the era of mass
incarceration this is not a piece of
analysis
this is a piece of supposed reportage
amazing that nobody in the democratic
party discovered that joe biden was a
tough on-crime democrat in the 1990s
until just the minute they seek to sink
him in the nomination process
weird how that works wasn't he vp for
like eight full years
here's what the new york times says he
now plays down his role over whole
overhauling crime laws with segregation
of senators in the 80s and 90s
that portrayal today is at odds with his
actions and rhetoric back then
so the idea is that if he was tough on
crime back in the 80s and 90s it's
because
he was secretly in league with
segregationists
now this is incredibly stupid one of the
reasons it's incredibly stupid
is many of the people who are very much
behind better policing in the black
community
were members of the black community who
were pointing out that the crap crack
epidemic
was wrecking an enormous number of lives
in the black community in fact
federal government and states getting
tougher on law enforcement in 1994
reversed a 30-year
downward spiral in violent crime in the
united states it's one of the most
dramatic stories
in american public policy history the
fact that joe biden is now being dragged
through the mud over it is fairly insane
we get to live off the benefit of the
fact that we got tough on crime in the
1990s now we could say oh well you know
crime
it's really down that means we can
loosen up our laws we'll see how that
works out i am very skeptical that works
out well
but to suggest that because joe biden
was worried about crime
during the highest crime time in modern
american history
to suggest that that was a problem for
joe biden because joe biden was
therefore a racist is insane but that's
exactly what the new york times
is going for right here so here's what
the new york times reports
in september 1994 as president bill
clinton signed the new violent crime
control and law enforcement act
in an elaborately choreographed ceremony
on the south lawn of the white house
joseph r biden jr sat directly behind
the president's lectern
flashing his trademark grin oh the
cruelty for mr clinton the law was an
immediate follow-through on his campaign
promise
to focus more federal attention on crime
prevention but for mr biden the moment
was the culmination of his decades-long
effort to closely marry the democratic
party and law enforcement and to
transform the country's criminal justice
system in the process
he had won the truth is biden boasted a
year earlier in a speech on the senate
floor
every major crime bill since 1976 that's
come out of this congress every minor
crime bill has had the name of one
democratic senator from the state of
delaware
joe biden now more than 25 years later
as biden makes his third run for the
white house
many calling for ambitious criminal
justice reform among the other democrats
he must answer for his role in
legislation that criminal justice
experts and his critics
say helped lay the groundwork for the
mass incarceration that has devastated
america's black
communities that he works with
segregationists to write the bills an
issue that recently dominated the
political news
and seems likely to resurface in biden's
first debate on thursday has only added
to his challenge
so has the fact that black voters are a
crucial democratic constituency now
here's the problem
black voters don't seem to care about
this stuff okay by polling data black
voters are not running away from joe
biden at this point now maybe that
changes but
at this point this belief that because
joe biden was tough on crime
when crime rates were at record highs in
the united states therefore he's a
racist
is ridiculous and insane you know how
many black lives were saved by criminal
justice
by increases in criminal justice
resources at the federal and state level
in the 1990s it would be tens of
thousands
of human lives were saved by that the
murder rates in america's capital cities
were skyrocketing throughout the 1980s
culminating in the early 90s
and then the government decided hey
maybe we better get tough on crime
instead of following these lefty
protocols
on exactly how crime ought to be fought
and the crime rates started to drop
in fact if you want a more prosperous
minority community in the united states
if you want prosperous black communities
with a serious tax base with growing
economies with people who are able to go
to well-funded schools you know what you
need
crime rates to drop the only way to do
that is to have more police in these
areas
that literally that's the only way to do
this okay the reality of high black
crime rates in the united states
goes all the way back to the early 20th
century and before
and that was largely because the white
community decided that they didn't care
if black people killed each other
because racists decided they didn't care
if black people killed each other so
they simply would not allocate law
enforcement resources to the black
community
this ended with increases in violence
that was a result of white racism
then in the 1960s there was a decision
made by folks on the american left
that they would get loose on crime
supposedly out of sympathy for black
communities and crime rates skyrocketed
including in the black community
and particularly in the black community
and those differentials have never been
corrected between black and white crime
that is not the fault of race that is
the fault of government policy
that ignored for well over a century
crime in the black community because
people who were racist didn't care if
black people hurt each other
and then it was followed by lefties who
thought they were being sympathetic
if they pulled those resources out of
the black community and now you're
starting to see that again
one of the best things that happened to
the black community in the 1990s and
2000s with these was the decrease in
crime rates
that led to the capacity for investment
in a lot of these communities
this isn't a particularly supremely
conservative position
there's a columnist for the los angeles
times
jane lavy she wrote a book on this about
crime rates in
it i believe it's called crimeland
something like that in in los angeles
specifically in los angeles and what she
talks about
is the fact that contrary to popular
opinion what is actually needed in
high crime areas is not fewer arrests
it is more law enforcement presence
people living in the community
people who are visible on the streets
people working with those people
the fact that joe biden is getting
dragged through the mud over all of this
is fairly insane and it's being led
let's be frank about this is not being
led
by members of the black community this
is being led by the progressive woke
credentialed class
who have decided that police are bad and
that the real problem is quote unquote
mass incarceration
when folks say mass incarceration the
question is which of the people who are
in prison are in prison because they
didn't commit crimes
in order to make the case that mass
incarceration has been a serious problem
in the united states you need to make
the case
that the people who are in prison are
actually innocent or are being
overpunished
so which people are those if you want to
make the case that low-level
drug arrests should be decreased i'm
basically okay with that case
but the vast majority of people who are
in prison are in prison for violent
crime
releasing those people on the street is
not going to make communities better
in fact it's going to make crime rates
skyrocket the combination of welfare
benefits that are created to help
single mothers at the expense of married
families and a crime policy that has
been loosened
over the course of the past few years is
making things worse
not better you want to know the single
largest factor in rising crime rates and
crime rates generally the single rising
factor in poverty and poverty generally
is single motherhood is men not in the
community there are two ways the men are
being removed from the community
one is voluntarily the men are knocking
up women and leaving
that is not just for black communities
this is true of poor white communities
in appalachia
hillbilly elegy jd vance's excellent
book about this makes this case
that high crime rates in poor white
communities are also driven by single
motherhood
that's obviously true it's driven by
that and yes people committing crimes
and then getting arrested
but if people commit crimes and are not
arrested how exactly is that going to
make any of these communities safer does
it
is the idea here that if men are out
there committing crimes these are also
solid family men generally
who are sticking at home and playing
with the kids at night there's not a lot
of evidence to support this particular
contention
so joe biden is not the bad guy here but
the media are going to try and make him
the bad guy just in time
for this debate it's amazing that i've
become a joe biden defender
i can't stand joe biden but the
democratic party has moved so far to the
left that joe biden
who is indeed a far-left dude is now
considered a serious moderate who's
going to be attacked on stage
for the horrible sin of working to
militate against
incredibly high crime rates in the in
the late 1980s and early 1990s
truly astonishing maybe it's time for
criminal justice reform that doesn't
mean that in 1994
we didn't need to delegate a lot more
resources to fighting crime
which we did and joe biden was right
about that he was right but he'll be
torn up and down about it anyway okay
in just a second speaking of fighting
crime and illegal immigration
we'll get to an amazing shift in the
minds of so many in the democratic party
in the media
about whether there is a crisis on our
border first we need to talk about
your rights when the founders crafted
the constitution the first thing they
did
was make sacred the right of the
individual to share ideas without
limitation by the government
that's the first amendment the second
right they enumerated was the right of
the population
to protect that speech and their own
persons with force that would be the
second amendment
so i love the second minute it's deeply
important to me
not only because i get a lot of death
threats and i need a gun to protect
myself but also because the second
amendment
is the bulwark against tyranny it was
meant to be so all the founders knew it
owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility building rifles is no
different started in a garage by a
marine vent more than two decades ago
bravo company manufacturing this is bcm
builds a professional grade product
built to combat standards they're
fantastic bravo company manufacturing is
not
a sporting arms company they design
engineer manufacturer life-saving
equipment
the people at bcm assume that when a
rifle leaves their shop it will be used
in a life or death situation by a
responsible citizen
law enforcement officer or soldier
overseas to learn more about bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
bravocompanymfg.com where you can
discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news that's
bravocompanymfg.com if you need more
convincing
find out even more about bcm and the
amazing people who make their products
at youtube.com
bravo company usa bravocompanymfg.com
listen go get one of their rifles they
are awesome folks
bravo company mfg.com meanwhile
controversy
again breaking out over illegal
immigration democrats
are trying to pass funding that would
presumably
alleviate some of the some of the
circumstances at the border which
there is a humanitarian issue at the
border there is no question there's a
humanitarian issue at the border
so what are democrats trying to do
they're simultaneously trying to tie
together emergency border aid
and trying to force the government to
release more illegal immigrants into the
interior
that's what they're doing instead of
alleviating conditions at the border and
making it easier for the government to
keep track of people at the border
and to process asylum claims more easily
democrats are forcibly attempting not to
do that
instead they now want to provide
humanitarian aid without actually
allowing for the more quick
processing quick and easy processing of
the people who are crossing that border
which of course
is not going to alleviate the problem
it's going to increase
the problem if you are suggesting to
people that if they evade the
authorities for long enough they get a
green card
or that if they or that if we don't have
more people at the border to process
asylum claims
that somehow this is somehow this is not
going to lead to more people trying to
cross between
ports of entry you're just dead wrong so
here's what house democrats are trying
to do the house passed a 4.5 billion
emergency border aid bill on tuesday it
contained provisions for the treatment
of migrant children
in u.s custody that democratic leaders
added amid widespread anger in their
ranks over president trump's handling of
the crisis i mean even notice how the
washington post
covers this it's not about trump's
handling of the crisis democrats
just three months ago were pushing not
to fund more beds at the border in fact
they're still pushing some democrats are
still pushing not to fund
more beds at the border take for example
the conflict between hillary clinton and
aoc they both tweeted yesterday
about the situation on the border
hillary clinton tweeted
i've been heartbroken and horrified to
read the news of children at the border
being detained
in appalling conditions no soap no
toothbrushes no beds by the way this
goes all the way back to the obama
administration before
not enough food babies being forced to
take care of babies everyone's sick
okay now we should all be concerned
about this obviously which is why
we should increase the amount of funding
at the border
for border patrol so what does aoc do
about this
the illustrious venerable intelligent
brilliant
fresh face so fresh so face aoc what
does she tweet
she tweets wayfare workers couldn't
stomach they were making beds to cage
children wayfair is the company that
makes beds they ask the company to stop
ceo said no tomorrow they're walking out
this is what solidarity looks like a
reminder that everyday people have real
power
as long as we're brave enough to use it
so just to get this straight
there's a shortage of beds at the border
wayfarer makes those beds
aoc is encouraging people not to make
the beds for the kids at the border to
presumably help the kids at the border
democratic policy on illegal immigration
is completely incoherent
and not only incoherent it is not driven
toward alleviating humane conditions at
the border
making them more humane it is directed
at increasing the number of illegal
immigrants crossing the border
and creating public pressure to allow
those people to move into the interior
in order to quote unquote alleviate the
crisis
that is the goal here so the house voted
along party lines 230 to 195
in favor of this border bill the
backdrop for the vote is not only the
humanitarian concerns about the surging
number of migrants but also president
trump's threats delayed but not canceled
saturday to begin a mass deportation of
undocumented immigrant families
notice how the washington post uses
undocumented immigrants this is typical
media speak for illegal immigrant
these are not immigrants who are just
lacking documentation
the vast majority of people crossing the
border are people who are immigrating
without any claim to enter the united
states
most of the people who apply for asylum
in the united states are not granted
asylum on the basis of an asylum claim
democratic lawmakers have expressed
concerns about passing a border aid bill
that would not address both of these
issues
nidaloey invade who is the house
appropriations committee chairwoman
democrat new york unveiled changes to
the bill tuesday morning that would
require
the border patrol to establish new
health and safety standards for migrants
in its custody
as well as protocols for dealing with
migrant surges within 30 days
the changes would also limit children's
stays at influx shelters used by the
department of health and human services
to no more than 90 days and require the
department to report to congress on
their use now all of that sounds
innocent and wonderful until you
recognize that democrats are
simultaneously
defunding and preventing additional
funding for the courts that would
process these people
so basically what democrats are doing
they're saying to border patrol you need
to certify that you're keeping people in
humane conditions also
here's none of the money that you need
and also you need to release people if
they're not processed within 90 days and
we won't give you the resources to
process
what do you think is the predictable
effect of these two policies combined
the predictable effect is to grant a
legal waiver so that people and
people can enter the country based on
shortage of resources that democrats
themselves refuse to provide
that's what's going on here because 4.5
billion ain't going to do it
additional changes low unveiled tuesday
afternoon would bar hhs shelter
contractors who do not provide adequate
accommodations food and personal items
such as toothbrushes as well as routine
medical care schooling leisure
activities and other basic services
listen i think we should provide all of
these things
you know how we should provide them by
also increasing the amount of resources
we dedicate
to processing the claims so we can make
sure that people who are not supposed to
be here
do not remain here you know how we can
change this by negotiating a deal with
the mexican government
that they are a safe third-party country
just like canada is a safe third-party
country
if you're applying for asylum you do so
in the first country upon which you set
foot that is outside your home country
you know how we can do this
by changing the law to allow people to
apply for asylum from mexican territory
as opposed to being housed in u.s
facilities
by the way four democrats voted against
this thing they thought that it was even
more important not to fund anything at
the border than to fund anything at the
border
those democrats were ayanna pressly aoc
ilhan omar and rashida taliba of course
of course the cadre of radicals inside
the democratic caucus
house vote was not expected to garner
significant republican support
the white house announced it was opposed
to the bill on monday house gop leaders
said they favored a competing
bipartisan bill that passed the senate
appropriations committee on a 30-1 vote
last week
so it's bipartisan that senate bill no
republicans basically voted for this
bill because it's a bad bill
kevin mccarthy the house minority leader
he said um guys you could just pass the
bipartisan senate bill that we passed
there are some republicans who are not
in favor of the bipartisan bill even
but the fact is that that is a better
bill than the house bill
the two chambers now have only two days
to spare before lawmakers are set to
leave washington for a week-long
holiday recess hhs has already warned
congress it will exhaust its funding for
housing migrant children
at the end of the month a scenario that
would impede efforts to move them out of
border control
facilities the senate is poised to vote
this week on its own 4.6 billion
emergency spending bill that included
2.9 billion dollars for the department
of health and human services
to address the large numbers of
unaccompanied children arriving at the
border
senate majority leader said mitch
mcconnell said that it was time to
get this thing done why is the house
trying to hold this up specifically
by creating provisions designed to allow
people to be released into the interior
by law
the senate bill includes 50 million
dollars more than the house bill for
immigration judges to speed the
adjudication
of asylum claims and 61 million dollars
in back pay for ice agents that
democrats in the house
refuse to provide representative chuck
fleischman of tennessee
the ranking republican on the house
appropriations subcommittee said
republicans are especially unhappy with
the lack of funding for immigration
judges and restrictions on ice
on ice funding he said this should have
been an easy situation
but nothing is easy when it comes to the
border
house speaker nancy pelosi suggested
that a vote against the house bill was a
vote for donald trump and his inhumane
outside the circle of civilized
attitude toward the children
she said that that basically we are
going to hold
up the senate bill and president trump
came out and he blasted all this we'll
get to the democratic response to trump
trump's response to all this and the
media who are just
damned liars we'll get to that in just
one second but first
with the ever increasing numbers of car
makes and models it's now impossible to
stock all the parts you need in a
traditional chain storefront
why endure the often pointless or
seemingly intimidating questioning like
is your odyssey an alex or an ex and
then you wait while the counterman
orders the parts on his computer
and it turns out that he only has like
one part at the store
you have computers and those computers
have internets
and those internets have access to
rockauto.com at home and in your pocket
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
go to rockauto.com shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need and a few
easy clicks
delivered directly to your door they've
got amazing selection reliably low
prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go check them out right now
rockauto.com
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
they know that we sent you that helps
out the show and it helps out our
advertisers
remember go to rockauto.com and write
shapiro and their how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
okay we're going to get to
the insane hypocritical democratic and
media response to the situation on the
border in just a second first
go subscribe over at dailywire.com 9.99
a month or 99
a year with the 99 a year you get all
sorts of great benefits
you get to be in the mailbag which you
do every friday you get an additional
two hours of the show every day i mean
we are working hard
for you you get this the very greatest
in beverage vessels the leftist tiers
hot or cold tumbler
feast your eyes upon it and you help
protect us from the vicissitudes of our
internet
big tech overlords there's a story
yesterday we'll get to a little bit in a
little bit on the show
about google employees labeling me and
this show
nazi materials this show i mean
if i'm a nazi i'm so deep undercover
that even i don't know i'm a nazi it's
unbelievable
but according to our big tech overlords
you know they could take us off the air
at any minute on some of these tech
outlets that is why you should go
subscribe to make sure that you can
still get the material
to make sure that you can still hear the
news that you want to hear
with the conservative commentary that
you want go check us out right now
please subscribe it really does help us
go check us out at daily wear we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in america
[Music]
so president trump came out yesterday
and he said listen the democrats don't
support anything
they've been trying to hold us up on
every front and when you look at what
the house is doing
by not providing the resources necessary
to process people which effectively
forces
people to be released into the interior
he is not incorrect
we're trying to get the democrats to
agree to
really give us some humanitarian aid
humanitarian money
but with that if we can get this bill
signed we'll be able to do it we have
you know the
democrats don't want to sign anything
and
now i think they're going to probably
sign this from what i understand it's i
call it humanitarian aid
what we would like to do and i'll do it
right now officially
is ask the democrats to give us
help board asylum help on all of the
loopholes the horrible loopholes that
get
signed in over a period of years that
don't allow
us to do what we should be able to do we
need
the votes of democrats okay and he's not
going to get the votes of democrats
democrats are busily blaming president
trump
for the situation on the border even as
they withhold the funding that he needs
on the border even as they do not give
him the resources that he requires
in order to process asylum claims for
people trying to get into the country
in a second i'll show you what the
predictable effect of this is here's
dick durbin
the ridiculous senator from illinois
blaming president trump for the
situation on the border despite the fact
that inhumane conditions
go all the way back to the 1980s and all
the way forward through the obama
administration and nobody in the media
or the democratic party gave
any craps about it here is dick durbin
suddenly it's trump's fault
the buck stops here when it comes to the
president it's his decision
look at his record willie first he
started us with a muslim travel ban
then he eliminated the daca program
protecting 790
000 people then he said no protection
for those under temporary protected
status
then they took 2880 children infants and
toddlers away from their parents and
tossed him in a bureaucratic sea and now
he's calling for mass arrest
it's the president make no mistake we've
had four
different secretaries over at department
of homeland security
and of course that's inexcusable but
ultimately it's the president's
responsibility
again every claim that he makes about
what trump has done either the obama
administration did it
it's forced by court order or the trump
administration has refused to release
adults into the interior of the united
states
without keeping tabs on them which is
actually what democrats want so
here's what's happening right now we
have a shortage of resources on the
border to process asylum claims
very few people are being processed
because our resources are spread so thin
statistically speaking we have seen a
massive uptick in the number of illegal
immigrants attempting to cross the
border
particularly since november december of
last year now the media are finally
realizing it and naturally it's trump's
fault despite the fact that back in
november december january february he
was saying we've got a crisis
on the border and the idea was that
democrats said no no it's a manufactured
crisis
it's not a real crisis it's a
manufactured crisis
now the truth is that the escalation of
the crisis happened in january february
and march
partially i'm sure as a result of the
fact that democrats refuse to work with
president trump on any of this stuff
and let's go back to that period for
just a second
and point out exactly how members of the
media treated the supposedly
manufactured crisis so here's jim acosta
and ladies find you a man who loves you
like jim acosta loves jim acosta here's
jim acosta of cnn you'll remember this
reporting from the border standing next
to a fence and explaining that there is
no emergency on the border
and here are some of the steel slots
that the president's been talking about
right here as you can see yes you can
see through these slats
to the other side of the u.s mexico
border uh but as we're walking along
here we're not seeing any kind of
imminent danger there are no migrants
trying to rush toward this fence uh here
in the mcallen texas area
as a matter of fact there are some other
businesses behind me along this highway
there's a gas station
burger king and so on but no sign of the
national
emergency that the president has been
talking about as a matter of fact it's
pretty tranquil down here that's pretty
tranquil no there's no national
emergency
and then they're members of the media
here's a montage members of the media
explaining
this is absolutely a manufactured crisis
from chris matthews to everyone else on
msnbc and cnn this is just
six months ago and it was it was not a
manufactured crisis
at the time it was not and it certainly
wasn't by february or march
here are all the members of the media
doing this routine well there is no
national emergency at the border it's
all made up it's presidential fiction
because there clearly is no emergency
there's no reason for this on border
security ground
we don't have a crisis at the border
nothing has changed on the southern
border
if the wall was such a crisis why wasn't
that a priority so it's a fake crisis
the president is lying to the american
people about a national emergency
there is no emergency at the border it
all depends on you know how you say
there's a national emergency in a crisis
at this moment when there wasn't one
uh before what the president is doing is
manufacturing a crisis
there's a crisis going on there and it
needs to be dealt with in congress
is it a crisis just because you call it
there's chris cuomo of cnn
is it a crisis just because you called
that well that was their message back in
january
and february okay now their message is
that this crisis is unprecedented which
is what trump was saying back in january
and february okay there was a serious
situation at the border it was
exacerbated by the fact that the media
refused to call it a serious situation
at the border but now they've realized
hey wait a second there's a serious
situation
at the border so today let's start with
the new york times the new york times
and the associated press
everybody printed this photo of drowned
migrants
it's a horrible photo a horrible
horrible photo
it's a photo of a of a man named oscar
alberto martinez ramirez he died with
his 23 month old daughter valeria as
they tried to cross from mexico into the
united states it is a horrifying photo
of a dead child with her dead father
apparently what happened here is that
trying to cross between ports of entry
because people were not being processed
fast enough at ports of entry due to
wait for it
shortage of resources because of all
that
because of all that this father tried to
swim his daughter across the river he
then proceeded to leave his daughter
across the river and go back across the
river for his wife
at which point his 23 month old daughter
being a 23 month old and i have
small children tried to jump back in the
river to follow her daddy
first of all the like as a parent
that's inexcusable i'm sorry that's
inexcusable to leave a 24 month old
next to a giant body of water
not expect that the kid might try to
jump in the water and follow you across
the water
instead of just waiting at the port of
entry in which case both
father and daughter would presumably be
alive today just as a parent that's
inexcusable
it just it is it's irresponsible but
what creates the situation
the feeling among people that they have
to do this sort of thing well inability
to process people at the border would be
one thing
inhumane facilities at the border would
be another thing although
that wouldn't really be the concern
because presumably this father and
daughter would have then approached the
border patrol authorities and claimed
asylum because once you're on american
soil you can do that which is why
people are trying to cross between ports
of entry you know what might have helped
here a wall
because if they're a wall you couldn't
cross the border and then claim asylum
you would be forced into the ports of
entry you'd be funneled into the ports
of entry
democrats opposed that wall so the media
have been pushing out this photo and i i
honestly am not clear
on which dead bodies the media are
willing to show
it seems like an unclear standard and a
politically driven standard by the way
i'm not saying that they shouldn't show
pictures like this i'm saying that they
are radically inconsistent on when they
will show pictures like this so they'll
show a picture like this
or the drowned migrant famously drowned
on the beaches of turkey
trying to reach european soil in the
midst of the refugee crisis
over there they will not show pictures
from for example the bataclan or
from the orlando pulse nightclub
shooting or israelis who are killed
in in terror attacks so it's very weird
which which
photos the media choose to feature in
which they don't i would guess that
there's
a pretty significant political
motivation there but the photo was
obviously horrifying
and now the media have awakened oh look
there's an actual crisis on the border
so don lemon
last night saying will this picture move
the needle well i don't know
when the entire republican party and the
president of the united states was
declaring there's an emergency on the
border he needed more resources to deal
with it
you and your friends were busy
explaining that it was all manufactured
it was all fake
trump was lying he just needed a
political win and now all of a sudden
it's
will these photos move the needle with
whom trump has wanted more resources on
the border
for virtually his entire presidency and
that really escalated leading up to the
2018 election
here is don lemon say are we shocked
enough i don't know where were you three
months ago
how about that the salvadorian
government released a statement from
an earlier press press conference where
they say that the father and daughter
drowned on sunday the 23rd
and as they attempted to cross the river
their bodies were found
on monday they had that they're in touch
with the mexican authorities
to make arrangements to repeat patriot
the victims
this photo is is just tough to look at
i'm wondering though
is it going to move the needle here
is it going to move the needle here you
know what it moved the needle here
is if you guys had agreed we've got a
crisis on our southern border you know
it'd be great there
faster processing of asylum faster
movement
to deport people who shouldn't be here a
wall on the southern border
more resources for humane treatment of
people who are crossing the border
illegally i mean it's amazing the shift
is amazing
i mean it really is christopher chris
hayes over at msnbc says trump
dehumanizes everyone this is all about
trump dehumanizing people
aoc voted against a bill that would even
provide the most basic increase in
funding for border facilities
and was designed to allow more illegal
immigrants to be released into the
country
is it about trump dehumanizing people
there is broad american agreement on
what to do here
it is democrats who have been refusing
the funding that is necessary
specifically for political gain here's
chris hayes doing this routine new york
times reporting a cbp official quote
said the agency was able to send about
a hundred children back to the station
because overcrowding there had been
alleviated the official disputed the
lawyer's accounts of conditions at the
facility
insisting that migrant detainees housed
by the agency were given access to
periodic showers and were offered
unlimited snacks throughout the day
perhaps it's not surprising that this
keeps happening when the people
running our nation's immigration
infrastructure constantly
denigrate insult and dehumanize
immigrants again the conditions on the
border have been consistent since barack
obama was in office and before
no one on the left gave a damn about
that brandon darby over at breitbart has
been doing reporting on this stuff
since i was working there he's been
doing reporting on this since like 2012
2013 and nobody cared about it no one
cared about it
because barack obama was president the
same new york times that printed that
photo
that printed that terrible photo today
that same new york times
has a had a piece january 11th 2019.
trump claims there's a crisis at the
border what's the reality
the reality is illegal border crossings
have been declining for nearly two
decades
in 2017 border crossing apprehensions
were at their lowest point
since 1971. there's one group of
migrants that is on the rise families
a record number of families have tried
to cross the border in recent months
overwhelming officials at the border and
creating a new kind of humanitarian
crisis
nonetheless the idea was that trump was
saying something that was false
this is how the media covered this thing
because they couldn't just give trump
the win
right they couldn't just allow trump to
say something true
and then we could all deal with it in
responsible reasonable adult fashion now
that was unnecessary we couldn't do that
we simply couldn't do that okay time for
some things that i like and then some
things
that i hate so things that i like today
and so i since the the democrats are
going to be
a a farce on stage tonight i figured it
was time to feature a comedy of errors
on the show so there's a play called
noises off that's been playing pretty
consistently in london for years and
years and years they made a movie out of
it with a great cast it's it's
people like carol burnett and michael
kane and um
and john ritter is in it he's terrific
and it
noises off is basically a farce about a
farce so it's a play that's taking place
it's supposed to be a farce and it
denigrates into even more of a farce as
the actors blow all of their lines and
are terrible at everything the movie is
really really funny it's kind of a gem
from the 80s
so here's a little bit of the trailer
critics everywhere are calling noises
off
one of the most hilarious films you'll
ever see it's screamingly funny
side splitting ripping good fun noises
off is a rib tickling hysterical
raucous riotous romp that's funny funny
funny
it's actually a very very funny movie so
you can go check that out
uh it noises off which is a great cast
very funny movie uh worth the watch okay
time for a bevy of things that i hate
so this veritable cornucopia of things
that i hate today uh that begins
with google so google apparently had an
internal conversation it's now been
uncovered by james o'keefe
in which one member of the google team
emailed other members of the
youtube team saying today it is often
one or two steps to nazis
if we understand that prageru jordan
peterson ben shapiro at all are nazis
using the dog whistles you mentioned in
step one i can receive these
recommendations regardless of the
content of what i'm looking at
and i've recorded thousands of internet
users sharing the same experience
i don't think correctly identifying
far-right content is beyond our
capabilities
but if it is why not go with meredith's
suggestion of disabling the suggestions
feature
this could be a significant step in
terms of user trust
so in other words in order to achieve
user trust we have to shut down opinions
we don't like and call everybody a nazi
sir this is from the trust and i believe
this this guy
is a member of the the trust and ethics
council
is the idea here nothing i trust more
than people who label me a nazi
uh just for the record not only am i not
a nazi i am probably one of the most
hated people by nazis in the united
states and white supremacists in the
united states
which is why the fbi arrested somebody
two months ago for threatening to kill
me and my family
finding in his house a copy of the
protocols of the elders of zion a phrase
a framed photo of adolf hitler and body
armor so that's good times over there
uh you know as as the person most
targeted by the alt-right on the
internet in 2016
as a person who has spoken out routinely
and repeatedly on the evils of the
alt-right and white supremacy
as a person who despises nazis
i think nazis are evil obviously i will
tell you i did not see this coming
i find it strange that prageru
run by dennis prager who i know
personally and happens to be
a fairly observant jew and also does not
like nazis
that prageru and jordan peterson whom i
also know personally and who spends
half of his is talking about the evils
of nazi totalitarianism
and judging people on the basis of race
these are nazis according to this person
over at google
and the fact that these people are the
step from
we hate nazis let's fight nazis to
everyone i hated as a nazi
was about one second that was about a
one second step
and that should scare the living hell
out of everybody it's one of the reasons
why big tech is under the gun
right now and you know what big tech
should be under the gun if they refuse
to provide any sort of transparency
that's right this goes from the
transparency and ethics council
there's no transparency because i have
no idea they're calling me a nazi and
then downgrading my videos presumably
i have no idea that they're doing that
but apparently they are
and when it comes to ethics nothing
seems more ethical to me than
falsely labeling somebody a nazi has
become the democrats favorite pastime of
late
and certainly members of the the woke
left this is their favorite pastime
of late it's insane it's insipid it's
disgusting
and look i'm a libertarian so that means
that i'm not in favor of regulating
youtube i'm not in favor of regulating
google i'm not in favor of regulating
facebook i don't want those companies
regulated i think the heavy hand of
government
may be your friend today but it will be
your enemy tomorrow with that said
if these companies do not provide any
standard of transparency how the hell
are we supposed to trust them
and you know what i can't hold back the
the i can't hold back the dogs at war
here there are people who are far more
militant than i
who are who are on the on the
raging against this stuff and raging
against this stuff and ready to regulate
this stuff because they feel like the
promise was broken
that google and youtube and facebook did
not pitch themselves as lefty outlets
that would only allow
material they liked to be featured these
places were not pitched as huffington
post
these places were pitched instead as
platforms
that were generally going to be generous
in their in their allowance of content
and if they have shifted that into a
left-wing
woke sensibility there'd be a lot of
people who say okay you broke the
bargain so
sure it may violate my principles to
regulate you but what the hell man you
broke the bargain so my bargain with you
is broken
not gonna play fair with people who
don't play fair i'm not one of the
people who is suggesting that
okay i have again come out against josh
halley's bill the senator from missouri
in terms of
regulating facebook regulating google
i've come out against elizabeth warren
breaking up big tech
but i'll tell you what the bubbling
seething undercurrents of hatred for big
tech is largely driven by the fact that
they are completely non-transparent
and that when they are exposed they're
talking about crap like this censoring
materials they don't like it's pretty
astonishing stuff
okay um you know what we'll stop there
we'll be back here
later today for two additional hours of
content so stick around for that or
we'll see you tomorrow for a full recap
of the first
democratic debate i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
robert sterling directed by mike joyner
executive producer jeremy boring senior
producer jonathan haye
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens
edited by adam syavitz audio is mixed by
mike coromina
hair and makeup is by jessua olvera
production assistant nick sheehan the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2019. democrats go
full open borders ahead of tonight's
debate
google admits that it is trying to
silence all of those scary nazis like
orthodox jew ben shapiro
and the washington post smears me with a
bunch of fake history we'll get into it
all check it out at the michael knowles
show